what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the latest developments in
the one piece story the serious waa no
fights have finally begun so make sure
to stay tuned for that if you enjoy
these one piece reviews and want to keep
them coming
make sure to smash that like button and
share this video if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial ring
that notification bell or you will miss
future one piece reviews for more one
piece videos check out our one piece
playlist link in the description feel
free to suggest one piece video ideas
you would like to see in the comments
below keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video we're talking
about the latest chapter chapter 980
after all now without further ado let's
jump into it this chapter is called
fighting music I think we're all excited
to see the real wah no fighting begin
during the last chapter Luffy got soup
spilled on him wastefully and it was
clear that he lost it he thought back to
Tama and how she usually had nothing to
eat and it understandably made him mad
that these guys had so much that they
could just throw it out and waste it
remember that Tama drank poisoned water
to ease her hunger and this chapter
starts out with one of the guys
complaining that the very edible soup is
not even worth eating another suggest
the very wasteful idea of a food fight
Luffy's had just about enough at this
point he thinks back how someone nice
like Tama could barely get a bite to eat
and how in contrast these terrible dudes
are surrounded by food more food than
they could ever eat he blows up his arms
her eyes of hockey and bam hits the
Laughing wasteful beast pirate right on
the head and wow this moment is a bit
reminiscent of when Luffy punch the
celestial dragon at both points he
wasn't supposed to do anything but Luffy
couldn't handle the injustice and just
landed the most satisfying hit you can
imagine I don't think this dude's head
will ever be the same shape ever again
and so Luffy gives up his cover and the
element of surprise people notice that a
fight is going on because of Luffy's
over-the-top attack Kidd not a very
patient guy himself is even surprised
for a second to see how quickly and
spectacularly Luffy blew his cover kids
men call Luffy an idiot because of how
easily the disguises would have let them
get right to the banquet hall but kid
ends up being cool with it probably
playing to take advantage of Lupe's
distraction it's
so funny because Luffy pretty much went
chasing after kids so kid wouldn't blow
their cover and of course Luffy is the
one to cause a scene first that my
friends is irony at its finest then just
this kid is looking calm again we see a
building get cut into causing countless
people to slide and fall if the
commotion that Luffy caused was bad this
one is much worse and of course we
figure out that Zorro is the one who cut
the building in half and yet he's the
one who calls out Luffy for causing
trouble again the irony is strong with
this chapter I just can't help but smile
when I see Zorro being the epic mad
light he is standing there like a
complete boss asking why Luffy can't
just keep his head down and slip into
the banquet quietly kids reaction is
priceless
he knows that soar was even worse than
Luffy so he wonders if Zorro can
actually hear himself and how ridiculous
he sounds we get another epic bromance
moment here added to the collection and
I gotta admit Luffy and Zorro are
probably one of my favorite bromance as
an anime so I can't help but appreciate
it when we get moments where they get to
shine together in this case Luffy
explains that the beast pirates started
it by throwing away a ton of soup
most people would rationally be like
okay Luffy who cares
that's got nothing to do with anything
but Zorro is on the complete same
wavelength and after hearing what Luffy
says agrees and says he's gonna have to
cut those food wasters to pieces and
someone understandably wonders why these
guys seem to care so much about suit as
the two talk in front of everyone about
how no one knows about them yet people
clearly start to figure out that
something is wrong and that they aren't
actually with the beast pirates fellow
worst generation pirates scratch Manabu
is the one who figures out that it must
be straw hat Luffy first up who is
surprised because he like most people
thought Luffy was in prison
just as the really slow beast pirates
hurt to figure out that Luffy and Zora
are suspicious the two start running you
got a love Luffy's big fat smile here
he's in the middle of enemy territory
dealing with two yong-chol and their
cruise and he's having the time of his
life
appoo contacts queen who responds in
rapper fashion which i can't help but
appreciate a pool let's qui know that
there are some escapees from Adan the
all-stars own turf then the musical
language continued
as appoo tells him to check out the mosh
pit where's ro and Luffy are kicking
some Beast pirate but a pool reveals
that they are indeed the worst
generations very own straw hat Luffy and
pirate hunter Zorro kid's spots up whoo
so we got four worst generation pirates
here in close-quarters which is pretty
exciting especially because one is
working with the enemy remember that kid
was screwed over by a poo op who
betrayed him and handed him over to
Qaeda in fact you could say that
everything that Kaito has done to kid
and his crew members can be traced back
to up whose actions so you know that the
hot-headed kid is thinking about payback
the spotlight goes to Queen who reveals
that he's going to be personally taking
down a flying six-member and thus he'll
be opening up a position he motivates
everyone present by dangling this
possible promotion in front of them last
chapter the idea of the all-stars
fighting the flying six was brought up
which was exciting and here Queen is
also fueling that flame so many epic
fights look forward to and it's so funny
seeing these drunk guys who are nowhere
near flying six-level saying they're
gonna join but hey a man can dream
especially a drunk man I also loved a
non gifter guy who says that non gift
errs don't stand a chance but hey that
means they can drink you can tell if
this guy's always fun at a party Zorro
notices that most of these guys are
smile users so most of them have animal
powers that means dealing with them is
less a walk in the park than a walk in
the zoo as Zorro and Luffy agreed to
make their way through the smile users
with their different animal powers op
who starts playing his piano teeth and
his other instrumental body parts he
mentions fighting music the title the
chapter clearly op who is a central
focus in this one and the poo actually
lands a solid hit on Luffy using his
music powers we saw some glimpses of his
musical powers before and they pretty
much let him use music to hurt people
through slicing explosions and alike
Luffy is confused about how Appu hit him
and Sora remembers that he was allied
with kids crew and he thinks the musical
pirate still is a poo gives Zorro a
slash on the chest
catching him off guard as well the worst
generation musician was no match for
Admiral Pisa who before the time-skip
which is completely understandable
because Kyoto is a super fast and strong
beast but a pool was
clearly always strong since he became a
member of the worst generation and his
bounty is 350 million berries we can
also assume that he got stronger during
the time skip just like all of our straw
hats dead
it also doesn't help that luffy and
Zorro have no idea what's going on
soraa's looking for the blade op who
used I can't see it of course since the
fighting musician is just attacking with
sound op who causes an explosion right
where Luffy is and he hits him pretty
hard
Zorro looks very worried and Luffy looks
like he's been at least temporarily ko'd
white blank eyes and everything queen
complains because he actually wants a
straw has to put up a better fight I
don't think anyone expected this to
happen during the first meaningful fight
Zorro picks up luffy and decides that
they need to run away as Zorro says they
can't be taking damage this early and
allstar hasn't even entered the fight
let alone a yonk oh they gotta conserve
their energy and stamina if they want to
stand a chance against Kaido Zora also
points out that this is an emperor's
crew which means that it isn't just huge
it also has a lot of heavy hitters a key
a talented and strong fighters Luffy
gets back to his senses and hilariously
bites down on an alligator's mouth
obviously we weren't expecting him to be
taken out by someone like Appu so it's
good to see him looking fine after that
explosive attack Luffy is convinced that
now they gotta force their way through
because the Beast pirates now know it's
that they definitely took more damage
than they wanted to take at this point
and aren't even moving as normal but
there can be no retreat now you might
recall how the samurai epically
destroyed their boats in order to show
how retrieving was not an option so they
got to do what Luffy is best at which is
just ramming straight into the enemy
just as op who says that Luffy and Zorro
are still in his range and threatens
them with another attack we see metallic
weapons begin to float
looks like Kidd has also had enough of
staying undercover he's mad at Appu for
betraying him and he's gonna get his
revenge with his giant metallic arm he
squashes up who we're told that the
backstabber got his just desserts and
all man was it sweet this chapter did
seem shorter than usual but maybe that
was me just flying through it because of
how exciting it was it's great to see
the action get on their way the Beast
pirates now know that
three members of the worst generation
are attacking them we see how much of a
threat the beast pirates are since Luffy
and Zorro couldn't even breeze through
scratch Manabu and they still gotta face
the flying sixth the all-stars and to
yonk oh not to mention the strong
members that show up from big bombs crew
right away were shown that you in the
earlier battles aren't gonna be super
easy ones nevertheless we got to see kid
destroy Appu by catching him off guard
and that was amazing he got his revenge
against the guy who caused his Kaito
misfortunes to begin
he was epic as we'd expect from kid and
this might mean that since he got such
sweet revenge against the pool the story
might leave Kaito for someone else but
right now it's definitely not looking
great for Luffy and Zorro although of
course they were trying to conserve
energy and weren't really trying yet
we're definitely gonna need some Yong
chol help here that's my opinion at
least unless Luffy unlocks gear five
ultra instinct as always let me know
what you thought of this chapter in the
comments and what do you think is gonna
happen next I always love seeing the
dynamic between Luffy and Zorro that was
hilarious and now we should be getting
serious fight after serious fight in
addition to learning more about Kaito
son Yamato can't wait for that but we
will have to wait an extra week since
the manga will be on break next week if
you enjoyed this one-piece review and
want to keep them coming be sure to
smash that like button like Luffy smash
that food waster if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial ring
that notification about or you will miss
future One Piece reviews for more one
piece videos check out our one piece
playlist link in the description and
feel free to suggest one piece videos
you would like to see in the comments
below
lastly the YouTube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime uproar patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive these YouTube issues
and who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
Twigg o himself
Efrain a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans Steven and
Rana Aloha autumn the world stealers
Tyson Kirino acquire respect potato fuh
Jonathan king deci deed brandon of isles
Smurf Emperor otaku and Richie Martinez
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing about a fan
Jason Wilson King cell just Anatole
kazansky angel Cruz I Sparky 65 cricket
XP Ted no Ted Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alicia actor animal 69 Jessica Calif on
he no commie and water
Bonnie parks zodia are 12 with two and a
hora Tian Wong Mitch loves anime cynical
crack him and JCCC wakka thank you all
so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
and Meowth Pro and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
your gear name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course bank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
you're interested you can also now join
the YouTube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer which
ever way you choose to support us you
can get the same great benefits thanks
again and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]